I'm like
I'm a person too I think I have more to
offer than just my dad
so it becomes like
tricky because like I get it Eminem's
daughter Haley Jade's not trying to lose
herself in her dad's shadow
[Music]
bearing and ask me anything themed
episode of her just a little shady
podcast Haley reveals this is the
question that came up the most does it
bother me
when I get asked about my dad because a
lot of the questions were about my dad
she has been
my main like source of drive and
motivation I feel like
the the best way to say this is yes and
no it's to a point so like
I obviously expect it and there are
certain things I can understand
why people are just genuinely curious
about right
as anyone would be when you've kind of
grown up like half in
the spotlight as Eminem's fans know
Haley's no stranger to the fame the
rappers made references to her and his
music including his music video for his
2004 hit Mockingbird which was made up
of home movies from Haley's childhood
Kaylee I know you miss your mom and I
know you miss your dad when I'm gone but
I'm trying to give you the life that I
never had truth is
he's all I got in this world like really
with everything into tomorrow she's all
that I have and while she was born into
this Fame Haley thinks there should be
some Grace from Outsiders looking into a
life lived in the public eye once it
gets past that point though
I'm like
I'm a person too I think I have more to
offer than just my dad
so it becomes like
tricky because like I get it then you
started seeing Daddy on the TV and Mama
didn't like it and you and Laney were
too young to understand it I feel like
growing up when it would happen I would
get more bothered by it because
I was like why do people care like I
don't know because I was young and I
didn't totally understand the situation
I'm just like that's my dad like I don't
ask you about your dad and there are
certain things that yeah like that's
just weird that you want to know that
but then like you know things that have
been a little bit shared I understand
why people are like okay is this true or
whatever but some stuff it's just like
that's weird
let's move on well despite being just a
little bothered when asked about her
famous pops she knows she's lived a
pretty surreal life because of him hi my
name is
I thought like oh everybody else does
this too not realizing that like no
that's freaking weird and like looking
back on it yeah when Haley's podcast
launched back in July she didn't waste
any time going into detail about her
childhood with her bff Brittany I
vividly remember being in your kitchen
and you were like do you want to come on
the tour bus
um and I was like casual casual
um normal conversations and I was like
what's a tour bus and somebody was with
us and they were like Haley Jade like
not everyone knows what a tour of us is
and you're like what like honestly to
you like that was I thought it was
somewhat normal yeah
when like something like that happened
and it's like so fun to look back and
like when we have these conversations
like here wherever like thinking back as
an adult I'm like wow that's actually so
surreal and like
those memories that like of me just
thinking like those were normal things
yeah now I look back and I'm like holy
crap
[Music]